quienes están preocupados por el medio
ambiente quiero que levanten las manos
quienes han visto basura cuando van
caminando por la calle
quienes se han quejado por esto
y quienes han hecho algo para cambiarlo
eso es a lo que me refiero hemos
cristiano en una sociedad en donde todos
estamos inmersos en el mismo círculo
vicioso en donde vemos una problemática
nos quejamos pero nunca hacemos nada por
arreglar porque nos han enseñado que
algún día va a caer algo del cielo que
va a arreglar todos nuestros problemas
pero déjenme decirles que tú y yo
podemos ser ese alguien que va a cambiar
el mundo
tomar las riendas de nuestro futuro es
algo que todos debemos estar pensando
ahora mi nombre es gabriel a carrero y
sé que crear un mundo mejor no es tarea
fácil y menos si no tienes a las
personas correctas a tu lado
soy scout desde hace 5 años este
movimiento me ha permitido conocer
personas que quieren lo mismo que yo
construir un mundo mejor además me ha
permitido vivir experiencias que no
cambiaría con nada y visitar lugares en
los que pude evidenciar cómo es la vida
es cuidada y preservada y en otros en
donde nada de esto se cumple como pasa
en las cataratas de foz iguazú un lugar
que pudimos visitar el año anterior un
lugar en donde la vida es preservada
valorada y no por nada es una de las
maravillas del mundo
como pasa también aquí en bogotá con el
río arzobispo un lugar en donde la vida
no es valorada ni preservada mi equipo y
yo comenzamos creando pequeños proyectos
como recolectar donaciones para
llevarlas una fundación scouts la cual
tiene como propósito ayudar a animales
de la calle este proyecto nos llevó a
crear alguno un poco más grande lo que
pasa con botellitas de amor un proyecto
que decidimos iniciar en nuestra
comunidad educativa el cual tenía como
propósito crear conciencia ambiental en
cada uno de los chicos y docentes nos
quedamos todos los descansos al lado de
las canicas día tras día ayudándole a
los chicos y docentes a aprender el
correcto se para miento de las basuras
esta iniciativa fue una tarea ardua ya
que nos implicaba estar en contacto con
basura que no era nuestra y algo muy
curioso que pasó fue que esta iniciativa
hizo que nuestro colegio nos empezaron a
llamar las locas de las basuras un
término que no nos molestaba ya que esto
implicaba que estábamos haciendo algo en
la mente en nuestra comunidad
así fue como comenzamos con el proyecto
del árbol road el balance perfecto entre
tecnología y naturaleza
el árbol roth trabaja por más de 400
árboles naturales
gracias al uso de microalgas las cuales
son las encargadas de realizar el
proceso fotosintético en el árbol robot
de una manera más fácil y eficiente por
qué ocurre esto hacer el proceso
fotosintético de la misma forma que la
mayoría de plantas el que todos
conocemos pero al ser organismos
unicelulares tienen una capacidad de
crecimiento mucho mayor a la de un árbol
normal al no necesitar estructurados
reproductoras pueden duplicarse en
cuestión de horas además otra ventaja de
esta especie es que ajustan su
composición bioquímica a las condiciones
de cultivo entonces por medio de los
fotobiorreactores que se encuentran
situados en el árbol podemos entrenar
las microalgas para incrementar su
productividad en la captura de dióxido
de carbono estas están ligadas y
contenidas en uno de los
fotobiorreactores los cuales le aportan
nutrientes y luz a las algas y lo más
importante adecuar las condiciones
ambientales para su óptimo crecimiento
el cerebro del árbol se encuentra en los
sensores ya que estos son los encargados
de monitorear la calidad del aire además
son autosustentables ya que funcionan
con energía solar pero usted se
preguntarán
y hacer nuestro proyecto diferente y un
árbol natural
al ser completamente tecnológico
comenzaría a rendir al cien por ciento
desde el primer momento gracias a su
composición y los elementos que tienen
también este prototipo está diseñado
para las urbes debido a la poca cantidad
de espacio que ocupa puede ser instalado
en cualquier lugar hasta dentro de
edificaciones y seguiría siendo la misma
acción con esto reduciremos la huella de
carbono que día a día producimos aquí en
bogotá increíble no la creen
este proyecto nos permitió a mí a mi
equipo mantener viva la ilusión de crear
un mundo mejor tenemos 16 y 17 años
somos adolescentes como cualquier otro
pero tenemos algo que nos hace
diferentes
tuvimos una iniciativa y decidimos
ponerla en práctica que nunca se les
olvide si no es aquí donde si no es
ahora cuando y si no soy yo quien
gracias